hello and welcome to a special
world ocean day edition of the daily
climate show
on today's programme how destructive
fishing practices
are releasing carbon into the atmosphere
and damaging supposedly protected areas
letting nature take over the solution to
sea level rise
on the gower peninsula
and the fishermen turning the tide on
plastic
in the mediterranean
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes
happening to our world right now and
meet those coming up with the solutions
well today we're marking world ocean day
and this year's theme is life and
livelihoods
not only do our oceans produce more than
50 of the planet's oxygen
they are home to most of the earth's
biodiversity
and billions of people depend on them
for their main
source of food and our oceans can help
combat global warming absorbing
around 30 percent of the carbon dioxide
produced
by humans but they are under threat
in a moment we'll be finding out how one
uk community is adapting
to rising sea levels but first there's a
warning today
that our seas are in a death spiral from
climate change
and destructive fishing greenpeace says
that the chemistry of our waters is
rapidly
changing as boats using fishing methods
such as bottom trawling
stir up carbon dioxide and deplete
already
low fish stocks well damaging fishing
practices
are a huge issue around the world as our
science correspondent thomas moore
reports the ocean is in a death spiral
says greenpeace
and they're on a mission to protect it
for six months they'll patrol marine
conservation zones along the south coast
looking out for destructive forms of
fishing factory trawlers with nets a
mile long
and boats that drag heavy equipment
along the fragile seabed
we're seeing the ocean facing more
pressures than ever before we're seeing
climate change we're seeing plastic
pollution we're seeing overfishing
and they're all interacting with each
other to create quite a dangerous
situation
earlier this year greenpeace found
evidence of unregulated fishing by
chinese trawlers in the indian ocean
some turn off their satellite trackers
to hide from authorities
it's likely to be happening in uk waters
too
this isn't just about fish stocks and
biodiversity it's about the climate
too protected areas in the uk's offshore
waters contain an estimated 26 and a
half
million tons of carbon and when fishing
gear is dragged along the bottom
all that gets stirred up
environmentalists and those trying to
eke out are living from small boats are
now often on the same
side martin barely catches enough fish
to pay for his fuel
i think we're facing uh an environmental
disaster here
we were catching sort of 30 odd boxes
and now we're down to around about a box
and a half
the government has plans to ban all
destructive activities in some
protected areas but greenpeace says more
needs to be done
more quickly to keep the ocean healthy
thomas more sky news in new haven
now one of the ways that we track the
impact of global warning on our planet
is of course through sea level rise it's
mainly caused by two factors both
related to global warming well the one
that we've often talked about on this
show is water from melting ice such as
glaciers and ice sheets
the second though is thermal expansion
water expands as it gets warmer so
as our oceans heat up those sea levels
rise
well global sea levels have risen
between 21 and
24 centimeters since the industrial
revolution
and crucially the rate of that rise is
accelerating
more than doubling from 1.4 millimeters
per year throughout most of the 20th
century
to 3.6 millimeters per year
from 2006 to 2015.
and the impact of those rising sea
levels is already being felt in
the uk in 2014 the sea wall at kamivi on
the gower peninsula in wales
suffered severe damage but rather than
rebuild it
the national trust let nature take over
as sky stan whitehead reports
when i came down to site and the site
that had been an agricultural field the
previous day
was you know three foot under sea water
seven years ago
the sea wall defending this farmland on
the gower peninsula
gave way but rather than rebuild
the national trust controversially at
the time
let the water take over we don't defend
against the sea you know we don't do it
we understand that
you know habitats need to be dynamic you
know things need to be able to change
the results an abundance of salt marsh
brimming with flower and fauna
and locking in carbon most people can
see
that we've got really great nature here
you know if you come down on a quiet
morning you'll be able to see an otter
over 300 years or so there have been
attempts to repair this sea wall but
that effort has now stopped and there
are many
who believe that letting nature take its
course
is actually the best way to enhance
environments like this
we know that we're going to lose nearly
1200 hectares of intertidal area
just from coastal squeeze and coastal
pressure by the end of the century
so we need these small areas where we're
giving some land back to nature
letting the sea take over here has
brought in new life
and while holding the line against
rising tides is needed in built-up
coastal areas easing the pressure
elsewhere
can create new landscapes for years to
come
dan whitehead sky news kumaivi well with
me now is jacqueline
savitz chief policy officer for north
america at the conservation organization
oceana very good afternoon to you
jacqueline we've had
more countries pledging to protect 30
of the oceans great news how far are we
away from that being a reality well i
think we have some work to do
i know a number of countries are aiming
to protect 30
by 2030 um and i believe that's very
much possible especially if we
make sure that those protections are
meaningful enforceable protections for
our oceans it'll allow us
to rebuild our fisheries and protect the
ocean ecosystems
protections though do come at a cost
don't they so how long will it take
before the benefits
of that kind of protection will outweigh
the costs
well you know i think it depends on
different fisheries um what we've found
is that if we rebuild fisheries we can
actually feed
a billion people a seafood meal every
day
that's obviously a goal we want to
aspire to especially with food
insecurity
and so sustainable fisheries actually
has benefits not just for
food security but for livelihoods for
the economy
for the environment and that's something
we obviously want to work towards
yeah and that's what today is all about
isn't it and we saw also the
damaging impact of bottom trawling on
the oceans why not just ban it outright
um well it depends on where you are in
some areas bottom trawling may be
perfectly fine but in areas where we
have
bottoms that have high habitat values
they're the nursery areas there's
spawning areas
for fish those are the areas where we
want to prevent bottom trawling and that
will
be done we've seen that done in many
cases and that will allow
fisheries to thrive we also saw
jacqueline
in the other report that we were showing
some of the benefits
of working with rising sea levels jackie
and how
how far are we in adapting to that as a
reality
well i think you know adaptation is is
something that we will be able to do in
some cases and not in others
um and that's why it becomes so
important that we mitigate the impacts
of climate change that we address that
carbon dioxide emissions
um which you mentioned the oceans are
absorbing a third of what we're emitting
but it's making them sick in the process
and the only way
to stop that sort of runaway train
of climate change uh sea level rise
ocean acidification
is to stop releasing so much carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere and that
means moving away from the use of fossil
fuels
and shifting to clean energy which
doesn't lead to sea level rise
well jacqueline sava it's been
fascinating talking to you happy world
ocean day thank you for your time
thanks samia the same to you
well you can find out more about world
ocean day and indeed why it matters as
well as how important the sea is in the
fight against climate change that's on
our website
you just need to head to skynews.com
climate well let's take a look at some
of the day's other climate news now and
boris johnson has told cabinet ministers
that this week's g7 meeting is a chance
to reinvigorate
the international community to tackle
climate change
leaders from the uk us canada france
italy
germany and japan will meet to discuss
global issues including
the climate crisis and on friday we'll
have a special
g7 edition of the daily climate show
live
from cornwall and you can see that here
on sky news
at 6 30 p.m a campaign group is calling
on the government to
rewild a tenth of national parks to
tackle the nature
and climate crises rewilding britain
says the process
which restores ecosystems to a more
natural state
could boost jobs and help the uk meet
its pledge to protect
30 percent of land by twenty thirty
and water voles are being released in
yorkshire in a bid
to save the endangered mammal the
project by yorkshire water
is part of their water works for
wildlife initiative
it's a 1.6 million pound scheme that
hopes to boost
natural habitats across the country
water voles have suffered a
steep decline in recent years as a
result of habitat loss water pollution
and predation by the invasive american
mink now for an ocean-themed climate
diary today we are hearing
from lefteris arapakis he founded
greece's first
professional fishing school to teach
more sustainable techniques
but also to encourage fishermen to
remove plastic from the mediterranean
sea
[Music]
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family hungry fishermen for
five generations
[Music]
one day i was talking with my father and
he was complaining that the fishermen
couldn't find enough personnel
for the fishing village i didn't know
anything about fishing
i think even today i'm the worst
fisherman in the country
[Music]
in the last three and a half years we
have trained more than 115
unemployed people with a greek fishing
ship
i was shocked to see that the fishermen
were connecting with their nets not only
fish
but also plastic lots of it
we started training fishermen from our
port to bring
plastic back in the lab the fishermen
cut this blast by accident
so we give them the motivation and the
system to bring it back to the land
we have collected already more than 110
000
kilos of plastic from the bottom of the
sea
plunge for the future is to be able to
replicate
this model in other parts of the world
we believe that we can make an actual
difference and a real impact in the
world
well that is everything from us for
today tomorrow
it's a battle bus but not as you know it
we're going to be finding out more about
the uk's first fully electric coach on a
zero
carbon tour that's at the same time
tomorrow here
on sky news hope to see you then
you